look at how trump fixed this country
i just had jason riley on he's the the
brilliant black writer for the wall
street journal and he writes he wrote
this book the black boom
and the guy can't stand trump but he
also loves truth more than he can't
stand trump so he writes a book about
how good the economy was for blacks
unprecedentedly good
but do people care no they don't care
the people who claim to care about
blacks voted for biden who's ruining
things for blacks and for whites and
hispanics and everybody else the the man
is a bad man and a disaster the worst
human being to ever be elected president
in my opinion as a human being i think
trump is saintly compared to uh
to biden
so uh this is what there is no memory
that is that's the long answer to your
short question there is no memory people
don't remember what the left did they
don't remember listen
the stalin is popular in russia
the man who murdered 20 to 40 million
russians or and ukrainian soviet
citizens
is popular in russia
mao is popular in china he killed 60
million chinese now for every one of
those whom he killed think of the the
ripple effect of the people whose lives
were ruined because of that death and
he's popular his picture is ubiquitous
in china
people don't remember left-wing evil
they only remember right-wing evil
what do we do
this is what i went on a crazy rant on
my show this morning and i don't do the
rant that often right i'm a pretty
measured guy but what do we do
to the people that got us here and the
people that are still dragging us into
these seemingly endless uh this endless
pit of hell the kathy hoechel in new
york the eric garcetti who holds his
breath when he takes pictures uh gavin
newsom you you know all the people the
people who are still doing it uh despite
no scientific evidence
do we need to have some kind of
nuremberg trials what i mean should they
be just banned from public office like
what would a healthy society do and i
guess i mean this not only at a
political level but for you also at
either philosophical or a spiritual
level it doesn't seem to me that if
we're ever going to really heal from
this thing we can just move past it like
we're in the phase now where we're
moving past it because the democrats are
realizing they're going to get crushed
in the midterms but we need to remember
what these people did what what would a
healthy society do
uh in this greatest mistake of all time
right by the way you uh you hit the nail
on the head with your line
your penultimate line
of we need to remember so i was saying
on my radio show today
because there's a big recall for george
gascon yeah the ev the evil evil [ __ ]
who is the evil fool not [ __ ]
who was the district attorney
and the recall campaign against him last
year in l.a in l.a
in l.a he's the district attorney he's
just like the one in uh in philadelphia
san francisco
these are the george soros funded people
whose a sole agenda is to increase
murder
in the cities in which they work that is
their that is their agenda i truly
believe that by the way now if you said
to them
do you want to increase murder they
would say no we want to decrease the
imprisoned
but they're the same thing
okay there it's
it's it's like uh
you can't have
hot snow you can't have less
imprisonment and less murder
it's just i'm sorry but uh uh adults
uh actually you don't have to be an
adult a five-year-old would understand
that before they go to college they
understand a lot more about life
so i said it's interesting they probably
will recall gascon now because of the
murder rate in los angeles
and
this is what people do
they elect the left this is the history
of latin america for example they elect
the left the left destroys their
freedoms their country and their economy
and then they put the right in power
which fixes things up to a certain
degree or or more than a certain degree
and then they think ah we need more
equity and then they re-elect the left
and it's all a cycle people will not
remember what the left did to destroy
this country uh two years after uh the
the the
the right fixes it up look at how trump
fixed this country
i just had jason riley on he's the the
brilliant black writer for the wall
street journal and he writes he wrote
this book the black boom and the guy
can't stand trump but he also loves
truth more than he can't stand trump so
he writes a book about how good the
economy was for blacks unprecedentedly
good
but do people care no they don't care
the people who claim to care about
blacks voted for biden who's ruining
things for blacks and for whites and
hispanics and everybody else the the man
is a bad man and a disaster the worst
human being to ever be elected president
in my opinion as a human being i think
trump is saintly compared to uh
to biden so uh this is what they there
is no memory that is that's the long
answer to your short question there is
no memory people don't remember what the
left did they don't remember listen
the stalin is popular in russia
the man who murdered 20 to 40 million
russians or and ukrainian soviet
citizens
is popular in russia
mao is popular in china he killed 60
million chinese now for every one of
those whom he killed think of the the
ripple effect of the people whose lives
were ruined because of that death and
he's popular his picture is ubiquitous
in china
people don't remember left-wing evil
they only remember right-wing evil so so
if we accept that and i do i accept that
people don't remember and i accept that
these things are cyclical and the left
ruins things and then the right fixes it
you know i come from new york they're in
new york city david dinkins demolished
progressive lefty demolished new york
city who had to fix it scary rudy
giuliani uh
scary and air quotes obviously um but
okay but putting aside that that we
accept that what could in your perfect
world what would we do to to break that
cycle i mean what what would a healthy
society not what we're in right now what
would a healthy society do so that we
would not forget so we could break that
cycle
there are many answers to that question
dave
first uh the first thing that came to my
mind may not be the first thing to do
but the first thing that came to my mind
is take your kids out of school
homeschool your children
that that is the greatest single good i
can think of
to demolish the evil that the left has
become
and
uh
because the roots of it are all in
education
for all of my career i have had this
lying dave
i'll take a call
and somebody will say something i
consider particularly stupid
and i will then say
in my deadpan manner
sir i'm just curious what college did
you go to
and
you know i've really set him up because
he'll then say what makes you say i went
to college
which prepares me for my prepared line
and that is because only someone who
went to college would say something that
stupid
and the the only exception to that is
graduate school you become even more
stupid do you know that the new york
times even published uh that uh with
graduate school then i'll come back to
what we can do in graduate school as you
get more educated you are more fearful
of covid
in other words everything
yeah
i'm sorry yeah how much more info do you
need it the proof is in the pudding they
make people the proof is in the pudding
that's right
every awful thing
increases as you get more educated
now not real educated be i'm crazy about
education
i but if if you love education you must
hate most of american schools so the
first thing i think about what to do
take your kids out of the schools
that defunds the schools not defund the
police defund the schools take the money
and give it to parents to do what they
want with it to educate their children
so that that was one all right so you
but you're really asking if i have it
correctly
uh
is what do we do about the bad guys yeah
frankly
and continue to do it
correct
uh
uh i am i am only interested in
defeating them not punishing them if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell